my question is what role was your wife
in this situation because she came in
very sweet lady introduce yourself she
says Hi I'm the liver Queen yeah I go oh
damn the queen
so I'm assuming she must have known what
you were doing
um that's my assumption I'll let you
answer that obviously I'll let me say
two things about that because yeah
earlier when you're like okay who do you
have around you that's better than you
and I don't really want to share
publicly who that is but I'll share
publicly that there's no doubt that my
wife is number one you know when I knew
her when I first met her I knew she was
way better than me she's still way
better than me
um you know we got this thing in our
household um loyalty above all that
comes from her you know you come home
with a dead body
that person helps you to figure out how
to bury it right and then you talk about
the ethical and moral quandary later and
you deal with that internally
um what I'll tell you is that um I've
never lied to my wife my wife knows
about this
um we're dealing with that internally as
well I don't know if that that partially
answered your question yeah no I mean
just because
to come clean and the whole world and
even your best buddies didn't know about
this but it seems like there was at
least one or two people that knew the
person that found the emails they knew
obviously and now your wife
so
to be in love with your wife and her and
being your corner I feel like that would
be a double lie in your life so at least
you guys at least had this Bond right
you know like so you're not apologizing
to her that whole thing but now they're
still apologizing to her I mean look at
how I've drugged her into this yeah but
she knew the whole time brother so it's
not like she didn't know so she at any
point should have said Brian
what are we gonna do like it's one of
and like let me just but you did
steroids you didn't rip off a billion
people you're not burning made of you're
not Sam bakeman free like I'm I'm
listening to all this I'm like all right
so Brands and [ __ ] steroids and lied
about it okay so you know the so I like
I'm trying to in the context of the
greater scope of things what Pat is
saying it's not I'm not like what a
scumbag bro I'm just like all right
that's not what it is but at the same
time she was very much in the know
so you know what's your question well he
I was going somewhere with this but you
know just the relationship with your
wife you didn't lie to her about that
right so you're saying that you're
dragging her into it but she kind of
dragged herself into it she knew to me I
just want to protect her I mean I know
that this is my job as a man also right
is to fight to provide and to protect
and and I'll stop at nothing to protect
her and so what what you're saying may
be accurate yeah um in my mind this is
my responsibility as a man to always
protect her and so um that's what I'll
say about it but by the way if I if I
may from a different perspective as a
married man uh
you would die to have a wife like that
just just just to just to because you
don't know the conversations behind
closed doors that's between him and his
wife that's none of our business that's
between their business uh by the way
that's not the English I know you're not
all I'm I just want to come to the
audience that gets the context as well
dude Michael went to jail Francis went
to jail for God knows how many years and
he's been with his wife for 39 years I
don't know they just celebrate 38 holy
[ __ ] can you imagine you go so there's a
people like that you see and you just
have to say
man do you have a sister like it's one
of those types of things like can you
introduce me to your sister or a cousin
that has your genes and DNA because it's
hard to find yeah that level of loyalty
to be clear the question I was asking is
at least you weren't lying to her this
whole time that'd be a different
situation it's like not only am I lying
to the public and my kids and my friends
and my family it's I'm also lying to the
person that I sleep with next every day
that's a different type of regret that
you would have that's what I'm doing
listen a friend a friend of mine went on
if there's one person that knows you're
on stuff is your wife you know why and
again I'm not getting into the personal
stuff because when you are you have to
go two or three times a day okay so if
your wife is interesting we would like
going once every other day every three
days [ __ ] this guy wants me to go
towards the time I'm freaking tired I
got to work out to be able to handle you
[ __ ] it's like yeah believe
of that because testosterone level from
400 to 12 1400 dude she may be running
away is that true Brian I'm not telling
he doesn't have to disclose that but hit
that smile on his face says a lot of
stories go ahead man surprise because
your wife Barbara I was just curious
just get over that that's what juicy
Barbara your wife she's you know she's
you know seems amazing you know I follow
her on on Instagram I'm just interesting
how do you think how was she how was she
what's the backlash story because I'm
pretty sure because I know people aren't
[ __ ] talkers and how's she doing I'm
pretty sure people are hitting her up
and like I can't believe your husband
like how how is how is she going through
and how's it affecting her
you know I don't know she's she's uh she
says it all in her eyes yeah you know I
mean the way that she looks at me the
support that she gives me in her eyes
you know like um the way she puts her
arm around me the affection that she
shows me the physical love that she
shows to me
um you know we have just uh such a
healthy perspective on hate you know
what we've always said and what we teach
our kids and my wife and I this is all
like our principles our philosophies
that govern all of these actions right
is that
um when you when you hear a word
like these are just vibrations that
enter your ear and it's up to your brain
to assign meaning to it right and so if
you hear hate if you read hate it's the
same thing it's your brain that assigns
meaning to it and so the meaning that we
automatically assign is these people are
suffering and struggling and hurting and
hating the most the language that they
speak in is hate so we got to do our
jobs you know even more now it's like
it's so like if we read hate it's like
it's not like we perceive it as
something negative it's like okay we got
a job to do look look at how badly
people are hurting and so um I don't
know my my wife is uh I think we're both
very similar like with these attitudes
it's like it's a silver linings kind of
attitude did you get that from The Four
Agreements by the way no never read that
no where they say don't take anything
personally yeah just a reflection of
what so many people are thinking when
somebody's [ __ ] crap and they're just
going at you it's almost like you have
to stop and tell yourself like wow
what's really going on with that person
you know what they're built up so much
when I started my first company that
every email was like this you know and
it was like holy [ __ ] you know like you
just have to realize how bad they're
suffering and and if you understand how
bad they're suffering you can help them
right because I mean you know like the
natural inclinations okay am I going to
fight back you know they were coming to
you because they were suffering with
something in the in the first place you
have an opportunity to guide them to a
better life everything that we say to
each other is a metaphor for something
right the only way that metaphor makes
sense is when we process it and assign
meaning to it and if you always give you
know the illusion of hate the benefit of
the doubt it's like you know I spoke in
the hate language you know like after 10
11 12 13 I started to keep a list of
people that if I could get a gun these
these guys wouldn't exist anymore and so
um I know how to speak and I know what
that means you know I know where it's
coming from it's coming from a place of
deep [ __ ] hurt and so the second that
either of us see that you know it's like
well you know we feel pretty decent
about ourselves like we we know they're
not actually trying to attack us what
they're really doing is they're speaking
their own language and and we need to
help them I would just say my wife has
just been she celebrated her 50th
birthday a couple days ago oh happy
birthday and and we're having this um
this dinner she's she's 50. yeah your
wife that just walked in his 50s yeah
she's 50. she looks fantastic wow she's
49 right there oh great respect and and
here's the thing we're going around the
table and um we're sharing wins uh just
you know one of one of the great things
that happened previously uh on that day
and and so then I looked over at her
it's my turn and I'm like you know uh I
just got really choked up and all I
could really say was I love you but it's
because of the way that she spent you
know that this last week like because of
how badly I needed her and I never said
hey I need you you know but like she
knows and and uh and what she's given me
the strength and the support that she's
given me you know to to face this and to
do this you know there's no way I could
do this without her so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]